[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
so the real pleasure today to have a
drama Poe uh with us from our The Young
School of Medicine and the pH uh he was
a parenting major he's here
[Music]
his career
um and uh I think the only information
you need to know is that our governor uh
uh Lamont said Albert said our Dr Pat
okay so so you know he was really a
feels kind of normal that we're having
science on Saturdays once again so join
me in welcoming
well thank you very much Kurt for the um
really very nice uh introduction and I
really feel privileged that uh I'll be
the first Speaker after the long
pandemic and it's certainly important
for all the kids who have missed out on
science on Sunday during the last two or
three two or three years so
um thank you very much for the kind
invitation to to speak I'm going to talk
of course about everyone's favorite
subject now that we've left the pandemic
but just before that I think how many
here are scientists
how I hope all right the kids how many
want to be scientists yeah oh okay all
right let's let's let's let's let's get
into so so the the topic of today's
course to today's lecture is uh how we
use science to protect people from
epidemics
kind of uh an important subject now that
we've come after out of a large pandemic
and you know and so I'll go through
today about what are kind of maybe the
nuts and bolts and how we approach uh
these these epidemics are pandemics it
doesn't turn out to be like um
it doesn't
it doesn't turn out to be like this you
won't unfortunately see all these uh
Castro actors everybody's seen this
movie no all right okay well you
probably know some of the actors okay so
um you know so and it's actually a good
movie I liked it it actually tells you
some of the nuts and bolts uh you won't
be meeting these people on any of your
outbreak or epidemic or pandemic uh
investigations uh but I would um
um I would like I would refer you to
seeing the movie uh one thing is is that
you know today's subject is really on
science
and what we try to worry about we react
to or try to address is nothing spreads
like fear and the answer to fear is
science
okay so what I'll I'll go through today
is how I became interested in science
um I'm an epidemiologist as well as an
infectious disease physician and how
many here have heard what an
epidemiology the young kids how many
know what an epidemiologist does
all right good it's kind of a funny word
so I'll go through what an
epidemiologist does in practice and how
we use science to prevent infectious
diseases
I'll go through what causes kind of the
new infectious threats that were that
are going to that have emerged and going
to emerge and then how do we use science
to respond to those new threats and and
that I'll just give some advice at the
end uh you know for young budding
Sciences scientists in the audience
so let me start and let me start a story
not my story but my story of my parents
and and their influence my my mother was
a mathematician
um and she came to America to study her
freshman year in Boston
um and there she met my father my mother
was the person who actually gave me the
love of science you know through
mathematics Through Chemistry Through
Chemistry putting together as a high
school student molecules and so forth my
father was an engineer didn't really
have as much of an interest in science
but what he did have that motivated me
was a disease called tuberculosis my
parents met in Boston
my father came I think in 1953
in very typical immigrant story but
within two or three months
started coughing up blood he was at MIT
at that time they immediately took him
put him in a what we call a sanitarium
this was a refuge for where people with
tuberculosis got treated and he stayed
there for for two years this is kind of
the typical chest x-ray a solenoid
tuberculosis you can kind of tell that
this side is more wider than that side
this side actually has a cavity that's
filled chock full of of the bacteria
that causes tuberculosis and in those
days you put people into the hospitals
and these sanitariums and they stayed
there my father got daily ingest
injections of new antibiotics that came
out to save the lives of people with
with tuberculosis not only my father had
tuberculosis but my whole family my
grandmother my aunts in in Korea had had
tuberculosis
and that really highlights what I think
is a really unique side of what we do as
scientists and that's our contributions
to society
and these are some of the these are 10
of the greatest Public Health
achievements that happened not in your
lifetime but your grandparents Lifetime
and great grandparents lifetime
two of these are really very important
for infectious diseases infectious
disease was the leading killer of of
Americans as well as most people in the
world in the lat in the last century
and these great Public Health
achievements all of these including ones
like family planning or fluoridation of
of drinking water to prevent for a
dental for dental care all of these were
driven by science
and just to give you an idea of what you
as scientists can do
to
contribute to society
it's really captured in this slide it's
just a very simplified slide
800 of every 100 000 Americans in 1900
died of an infectious disease each year
you can see that this sharp decline
in the deaths due to infectious diseases
were really done to Great advances some
of them required vaccines some of them
required antibiotics many of these
things required what we in public health
and epidemiologists do clean water
good housing secure housing and social
rights rights to have rights to
well-being which created this last this
great large decline in deaths you can
see there's one Spike up here right and
we've just underwent a spike like that
with the coveted pandemic this was the
great night influenza pandemic of 1918
which killed hundreds of millions of
people
worldwide at that time but much of this
these advances in in public health were
all due to science
with different teams of people different
disciplines within science working
together to make this this large
societal benefit
and that benefit what didn't only happen
here in the United States but happened
throughout the world this shows this is
my lifetime I was born around this time
and within my lifetime we've seen
dramatic decreases in little babies
in little infants dying of of diseases
mostly diarrhea malaria
um
pneumonia meningitis
um this time even in the world's poorest
countries we've seen sharp declines and
with that decline in infants dying we've
had large increases in life expectancy
not only in the richest countries but
also in the in the poorest countries
much of this was driven by infectious
diseases our advances in infectious
diseases
sanitation hygiene
social rights such as good housing as
well as vaccination many of you who've
had diarrhea you probably May took
Pedialyte this kind of salt salt sugar
formula to prevent uh the long-term
consequences of of
um of uh diarrhea on on malnutrition
and so that was kind of my calling I was
uh as Kurt said I was a chemist
uh when I was an undergraduate one of my
professors said that why don't you do
something that maybe could have
potentially a broader impact uh socially
once you go back to what your father's
story was this was one of my first
mentors Nevin scrimshaw who was one of
the champions of nutrition good
nutrition sound nutrition for all back
in the 1960s 70s and 80s and that took
me after I finished my medical training
I went to medical school did my
residency in Internal Medicine and then
said okay where should I go and the
place that my mentors at that time told
me to go to was to go to Brazil and
actually went to a city called Salvador
it's some of you I hope all of you know
in Brazil it's in South America the
America is up here this city is in the
northeast of the country it's the oldest
city in Brazil 90 percent of the
population is African Brazilian descent
because of the slave trade intense slave
trade it's the poorest area of the
country as well
in this city like many others in Brazil
but throughout the world especially the
poorest countries look like this you can
see these high rises where the rich live
and you can see these disorganized areas
here they call these in Portuguese
the islands of inequality that occur
within these cities and this type of
phenomenon The Have and the have-nots
exists throughout the world
and to kind of show you this is taking a
public health perspective
why that happens so the first time in
human history
we have more people in 2007 living in
cities than we did in the countryside
this is all due to the massive growth in
cities people moving for the poor people
moving from the countryside to the to
the to the cities and by 2037 and this
is when you guys all grow up the
majority of the world's population will
live in cities
in the poorest areas
poorest countries of the world
and that that that change in
urbanization happens together with
changes in what we call social
inequality to have and the have-nots the
rich and the poor and you can see this
and one of the reasons that they told me
to go my mentors told me to go to Brazil
is exactly captured in this picture you
can see very clearly that one wall that
separates the Haves and the have-nots
okay you see on this this wall you can
see everybody has an apartment with a
swimming pool they have their tennis
courts
these people
go more to Disney World in Florida than
they ever will jump over on this other
other side of the fence
and that side of the fence is what we
call Urban slums or Urban informal
settlements
together in the world's population
roughly seven eight billion people one
billion of the world's population live
in these type of conditions
and these conditions of disorganized
growth people or squatters they don't
own the land that they live on
and this is this Picture Tells that
story this picture is from where we've
been working for the last 25 years in
Brazil
but this picture you can take
in Lagos in Africa you could take that
picture in Manila in the Philippines you
can see this picture many places of the
world you can see this is a community
where half the people
live on less than 2.5 dollars per day
this is a community that's densely
packed so people are huddled together
many times four or five six people in a
small small house so you can imagine
transmission of diseases occurring in
these very crowded settings
you can see that there's a lack of
Sanitation these open sewers and there's
no refuse collection taking out things
that we take for granted here in New
Haven
and in these this type this environment
you know which has happened due to
ecological changes this was this is
actually 50 years ago if you took this
picture it would be pristine Atlantic
rainforest now it's a densely crowded
Urban and formal settlement
and here in this type of environment
over what happened over my lifetime the
most successful mammalian species okay
the most successful mammalian animal
here is not human beings
but it's related to all these little
holes that you can see in this Earthen
stairwell
does anybody know what those holes are
yeah
rats yeah that's where the Burrows the
nests where the rats rats make their
Burrows so this is you can see very
close to where people live all these
boroughs where where rats are
and and this actually leads to what we
call a plague of rats this is an article
in the Science magazine about the
projects we've been doing in the
communities you can set out traps here
and capture dozens of rats
um uh in in a night
and there are certain diseases that we
worry about and we'll be talking about
this a couple times because this is
important for pandemics but there are
diseases that are carried by animals
that can spill over
and spread to humans and in fact cause
disease one of these is a disease that I
never saw when I was here in the United
States but I saw a lot this moment I got
off the airplane in in Brazil is a
disease called leptospirosis it's caused
by a bacteria a very thin kind of
corkscrew-like bacteria that Corkscrew
is important because that Corkscrew that
corkscrew
sorry the video is not working but that
Corkscrew allows the bacteria to travel
very quickly kind of like a screw going
through water
and and that's important because these
bacteria hang out in the kidneys
of these animals many different types of
animals but one important animal that
carries it is rats and they shed it out
as they urinate into the environment
they shed loads of these bacteria
into the into the environment and these
bacteria can swim and when they
encounter a human they can bore through
the skin
or you're the your you know the oral
let's see the tissues in your mouth and
your eyes they can bore through and then
they can spread proliferate and cause a
massive infection
and those people who get infected they
come down with renal failure they lose
their ability to their kidney function
they also come out with massive bleeding
from the lungs
you know what we call hemorrhagic fever
and when I
several days after I got off the plane
hospitals were filled with these with
these cases
and what we saw when we did our first
outbreak investigation sort of like that
team in that first slide for contagion
we got all these people together we
started to do an outbreak investigation
in back in 1996 the hospital was filled
with patients with this disease our
Intensive Care Unit where we treat the
sickest people we're all getting
you know dialysis because of the renal
failure or kidney failure and they're
also getting they had we had to put them
up to hook them up to a ventilator
because they're bleeding profusely out
of their lungs you can see that every
time it rains
you have these large epidemics of this
disease now come I'll talk a little bit
about a little bit later about why that
happens but these are outbreaks or
epidemics that happen in these
vulnerable
populations living in those poor Urban
slums every year very predictable
outbreaks that occur same time same
communities same same same people
and that gets us so what do we do about
that and that's why we have
epidemiologists
who are scientists dedicated for the
purpose of Public Health to keep people
safe so epidemiology and I think through
these talks you'll learn a lot about all
the different ologies but epidemiology
and all the different types of Sciences
but epidemiology
is the study of the distribution and
causes of diseases or health-related
states in specified populations
and I think most importantly it's the
it's the science of how we control those
health problems that that arise that's
kind of our our job to do
and it's actually a fun job you know
many times we're called into very bad
situations the coveted pandemic was one
but but many times the good the nice the
fun part of this is that we're always
doing something new or is learning
something new but we're also working
with a lot of different scientists we're
working with chemists like Kurt we're
working with sociologists economists
microbiologists people who study
bacteria and viruses we study we work
with a lot of different people so we
learn a lot and have fun doing that as
well as trying to do something
um uh good like uh controlling
controlling health problems and you can
see that many times if you're an
infectious disease physician like I am
many times we just think about the
patient
in the pathogen or the virus or the
bacteria but if you're an epidemiologist
you have to think about all of these
things you have to think if you go back
to the slides you have to think about
how's the environment
how much people are living on are they
able to survive are they being able to
be nourished properly
do they have some genetic factors or
biological factors that may influence
them getting sicker than others
and also are there other structures or
other factors like social factors the
type of leader that you have
that influences how well people are
going to get treated or how well we're
going to prevent prevent the disease so
this encompasses all of epidemiology and
that's what makes everything everything
fun
and the second thing that we did was not
only how to study it is what to study
but how we're going to study it
so this is a program that we started
when I stepped off a year after we
stepped I stepped off the plane we
already done several outbreak
investigations and we said hey
you know what we need to do is to train
more scientists scientists like you you
in the audience
and we had to treat strain them in many
different things
so the we started this back in 1996 one
of the most important parts is to that
that the best ways to prevent disease
is to do this through the community not
sitting in a university or not sitting
in a research institute but actually
working in the community
and so one of our foundational
principles was Community as equal
partners and what we did is similar to
what Curtin everyone is doing here is
that we we have we had high school Head
Start programs College work study
programs in the communities that were
affected by these diseases so that they
could so we could train scientists who
can solve their own problems where they
live rather than have somebody outside
come in and so these are actually our
high school students you can see that
they're you know we teach them how to
use a computer but one of the key things
in the computer that you can do is you
can analyze data you can analyze large
amounts of data and we can get that data
in kind of cool ways one things that we
do is give the students we have them go
out and we give them GPS devices almost
like Google does when they go by your
house we give them these cameras and
they can just take pictures along the
way we also give them drones the kids
like that all you know kids like that a
lot and so these kids are going out
using drones to find out all the places
that may be potentially transmitting the
diseases that that we're working on here
you can see some students here that are
going around and surveying all the
places where diseases like leptospirosis
that rap born disease could occur
and we use this to solve address a whole
bunch of problems one of the big Killers
when I came down was meningitis a
disease that we hardly see here in the
United States but a disease that we
could Pro we could prevent with vaccines
other diseases or diseases that are
transmitted by mosquitoes but the one
going let's go back to to leptospirosis
so this is a disease where you have to
have the rat because the rats the rats
the animal which kind of sheds the the
bacteria that infects infects people
and this is a and this is a very typical
scene this is the backyard
of almost everybody who lives in in that
uh in the study site where we've been
working where I showed that those photos
you can see that they're chock full of
rats
okay
rats I don't know if anyone here has
captured rats I I did it for about five
years and gave up and let let the
students do it but but
um but not easy to capture rats you have
to go out in the middle of the night
sometimes it's not safe
um they're
um sometimes they don't like the bait
you give them you have we give them
Gorgonzola cheese and bacon you know and
so it becomes a little bit expensive to
um to to capture rats so we had a really
smart Yale graduate student PhD student
Kate hacker that said hey maybe there's
a better way to do this and this is
actually science in action and she said
okay what's the cheap way that we could
do is should she took ceramic tiles each
Ones cost about 50 cents and she painted
them with ink
and then she laid them out like they
like here and throughout the community
and then she started counting how many
paw prints are rats or a rat or
sometimes rats like to scratch at these
um at these uh at these tiles so looking
at the Tails tail marks or the uh the
scratch marks
of these and using that and counting by
counting how many are in a tile she came
up with a way to make a map a map of
what we call rattiness places where a
more rattier than others okay and why is
that important so remember what an
epidemiologist does we're not there just
to kind of say okay this is where rats
live and this is where not rats live but
we want to use these Maps
and we now use in the in the past we
used to have to draw all this but now we
have computers that can really make nice
images but we want to we want to draw
these maps to tell us where do we need
to go
to do prevention where do we need to
know to control rats
if we can't do it everywhere what are
the places that we need to go first
okay and that's what this wrap tells it
it tells us
a big problem that I can be standing
here and there'll be a lot of rats but
if I go 20 meters or 20 yards there
the concentration of rats are very
different
okay and so we have to have not only
people who know where to go we also have
to have teams that know where to how to
control these rats we either give them
pesticides or we do education and we use
our youth groups to to to we could
actually teach the residents many times
the adults in the community how to
control their rat populations through
sequestering food not allowing refuse to
be stored securing water sources so the
rats can't drink or printing safe rat
Safe Water Supplies in these in these
communities
the other facet is is that
if a rat is urinating the bacteria in
the environment what happens if it rains
and this tells these pictures here tell
an important story in the daily lives of
these residents of urban urban slums
this is a very typical scene where every
time it rains
the the residents have to go into the
open sewer
dig it out
so that they can create a barrier so the
next time it rains
it doesn't overflow into their it
doesn't overflow into their households
this is a resident showing how high the
flooding goes
um in how high the flooding goes and so
in in these events you can see many
times they're going bare feet right
without any protection
so these these residents get exposed to
an environment the sewage water or the
dirt which is contaminated by the
bacteria and then the bacteria can
penetrate into the skin and cause an
infection and that's why we have these
these large outbreaks so again we like
making Maps so that we know who's at
most at risk and where do we need to go
and when we made these wrap uh these um
these maps and these is actually where
the geographer and an engineer
you know team coming in making helping
us to make these Maps the people with
the highest risk yeah go ahead
the water gets contaminated
what if the plants also be affected so
if you use a plant that absorbs
yeah that's a good question and that
that also is a way that that that people
get infected so you could be working
there
you know and your skin is exposed but
also if your plants or many times people
will store food like you know soda or
packages when it floods that all get
will get contaminated and when they eat
it the the the bacteria can enter into
the enter into the um the mouth what we
call the oral cavity and cause an
infection so that's that's an important
thing so you can imagine in this setting
where it rains and it gets flooded
everything gets contaminated
and the people who have most risk are
those people who not only live by an
open sewer but those people who are at
the bottom of the valley
so just to remind you this is an overly
poor Valley uh you know community
half these people live on 2.5 dollars a
day but you can appreciate that even
within those valleys there are people
who are more vulnerable than others you
can see that these houses are just have
much better structure than the ones at
the bottom of the valley that get
continually flooded many times in the
ones at the bottom they have to
continually raise their house because
all this silt all the sediment and dirt
from the top of the valley floods
um what it goes down to the bottom of
the valley in this situation you know
and many of you come from any you know
not only here in New Haven but many
different parts of the world you'll see
this situation where the most vulnerable
those at most risk for disease are the
people who are living in the worst
houses who are living by sewers who are
living in places that get flooded
whether it's in Mumbai in India or
whether it's in Guayaquil in in Ecuador
whether it's in Jakarta in Indonesia any
place in the world
and by doing this study and again many
of the this was driven by people like
you young students going out there
mapping taking taking a map where now we
have them on tablets we give them
tablets and drawing out where all those
open sewers are and and what we're able
to do is to do interventions going back
to what the principle of epidemiology
the goal our goal is to control disease
and so we had some some of our students
develop rapid tests much like what you
use for coven okay they they identified
pieces of the bacteria that could be
used to detect the the uh people get
infected so that every time it rains we
can alert The Physician and give them
antibiotics to prevent them from getting
that massive bleeding in their lungs or
the renal failure we also did rat
control we would send out teams working
with the government to to go Target
those areas where the highest rat
populations are but also the highest
populations the highest risk for for
getting this disease leptospirosis
probably the most important thing that
we did
was to work together with the community
and actually in a community
participatory model much like what
brings you here today
we're we're working with leaders we're
working with um uh the community and by
working together and at this time in my
life I was working with the Brazilian
Ministry of Health we were able to
convince
the Minister of Finance to give money to
close the sewers in all those regions of
the city
where they had had open sewers and high
risk of getting this life-threatening
disease
and by doing all of this we're able
within 10 years to get about a five-fold
reduction we we decreased the number of
cases of leopardosis that would come
into our hospitals every year by 90
percent no 80 to 9 90 percent so this is
a good example of not only science in
action but also an example how young
people can make a difference through
science and the third thing is that how
people from different types of Sciences
can work all together
for something that could could provide a
societal benefit
yeah so this this is um one of our
students who actually captured these
rats uh is dissecting the rat right you
know to find out what's in it and the
reason why they're in this hazmat suit
is because these rats are not only I
just talked about this one bacteria left
sperosis but they also
um are they are also uh carriers of
another of a virus which is very easily
transmittable it's called it's called
hantavirus
so every time you can imagine
Salvador where we work the city in
Brazil it's a tropical climate it's
probably 90 degrees not 80 humidity so
they're spending the whole day in these
suits doing their doing science right so
so an extraordinary team of Brazilians
and Americans have and and French and
English who have worked together to do
to do this study did I answer your
question yeah
what's in those rats yeah besides yeah
four leprosis and also not yeah
okay good so so so that's a good example
so I I wanted to start out with
leptospirosis because it kind of sets us
up
for a specific theme and this is a
challenge for not my generation anymore
but your Generation all the young ones
we are going to have
uh the question
um
I'm sorry say it again
[Music]
got it
here floods okay yeah so okay yeah so my
my house floods also uh in New Haven and
how many people have seen rats here
okay where do you see them
in basements in basements okay where
else do you see them
[Music]
okay yeah especially if you have food in
those basements yep
I'm sorry
sometimes in the attics sometimes so
there are rats which are bigger ones
they're also mice which are smaller ones
many times you'll see the mice you can
see rats in the Attic as well but many
times they're mice okay
has anybody here been to New York City
yeah all right anybody been to a Subway
in New York City yes all right anybody
seen a rat in the subway in New York
City okay
all right New York City's the Subways
are filled with rats so why why doesn't
somebody in New York City get this
life-threatening disease it does happen
but somebody in Brazil living in that
Community does
yeah so New York City has closed exactly
right spot on New York City has closed
sewers so when when the contaminated
water with this bacteria
doesn't flow into our bedrooms doesn't
flow into our play Space it stays in
those sewers the second thing is is that
that distance remember that that slide
that I showed about all those rat
boroughs those are right next to where
people live okay they have no option but
to every day walk through that area
whereas in New York
if you see them in the sewer they're not
right by where we are right and usually
we're not Barefoot right so we have
several barriers that protect us okay
this is why this is a disease of the
poor okay it's a disease that we see in
tropical climates okay and it's a sea
disease that we rarely see unless you're
traveling to Hawaii you know they have
they have left sclerosis in Hawaii so
anyone seen all the warning signs there
but very few situations where people
here people like you and I are going to
encounter leprosis
but this also kind of highlights some
some key themes about challenges that
your gen yeah please
rabies so rats don't carry rabies
they carry other diseases that we worry
about this is one of them right but they
they can also carry other these rabies
we're worried a little bit more about
dogs bats raccoons other types of
animals sometimes rabbits okay yep
please
so rats don't have rabies they can't
carry so some animals can carry a
disease and and not carry others and
many times and that's the question for a
scientist right you have to do science
we sometimes we don't really know why
certain animals carry some disease and
others don't carry another and that's
going to be important so I'll come back
to your question in a second okay and
that's that's important when we think
about Emer these type of emerging
infectious diseases
but let me go through some of these so
the challenge is Big challenges for my
generation is how to was how to improve
the health of all not just the rich but
also the poor
challenge for your generation at least
for infectious diseases it's going to be
the bigger problems and those problems
that are going to be caused by rapid
urbanization like I I showed in all the
communities that we talk to all those
disorganized communities that are being
rapidly expect that are rapidly
expanding the other is climate change
you can imagine how yep go ahead
um
yeah exactly well this this group
Kurt I don't think I have to give this
talk
I think they know everything
um all right good good so this is um
yeah so so let me give a good example
climate change is going to be important
so remember those people digging out
their their sewers
well those people have to
those people if it rains more and it
rains more violently they're going to
have to be exposed more and more to this
disease
okay so that so climate change with
these extreme weather events hurricanes
typhoons Cyclones monsoons this is
something that's going to be a challenge
for all of you in the next next decades
the other is the changing land use and
ecosystems you saw the precarious way
these communities one billion of our
world's population live and I think as
everyone it sounds like everyone knows
that we can get new infections from
animals
okay and there's several good examples
of that we'll go through covet is one
and then the other is that once we're
infected with a new infection we can
spread it quickly why because we move
much more when I was I think when I was
growing up for the first 15 years of my
life I didn't step outside of the state
of New Jersey
okay now my children have been all over
the world right like many of you will
okay so we're moving a lot more than we
did in the past and the other is is that
our population not just here in the
United States but many places in the
world is getting older
and older people many times are more
susceptible
or more have more risk of getting severe
severe infections so all of these things
are going to be challenges that you're
going to have to deal with in you know
in the in the future and let's get back
to the the uh the question before about
why animals so these you know some of
these animals carry rabies bats can
cause cause rabies uh camels have been
reported but very infrequently to cause
rabies but there are certain diseases
that we really worry about
that occur in animals that may spread to
humans the big one is influenza
many there's a current thought that the
1918 pandemic that happened was actually
due to Cross spillover or spread of a
bird influenza to to humans so that's
one of the things that we worry about
as we all know SARS cov2 cov1 is another
one okay the first SARS virus this is
back in 2003 This was
um due to spread from a civet that was
in a Marketplace and went to a
restaurant actually my friend did this
investigation in in the People's
Republic of China and found the
restaurant that actually was caused
caused that that spread to um to humans
and there's another virus called MERS
which is a cousin of the uh covet virus
which is carried by by camels and bats
can carry do many of these so you can
see that there are certain animals that
can cause infection but also certain
practices and certain behaviors that
place us at risk so for example Ebola
it's bush meat
um for SARS Kobe one it's many times
these what we call wet markets so these
markets where you bring wildlife animal
that are you used for consumption or
bird influenza we have huge farms in the
United States where we we
would produce a lot of chicken that get
infected with bird influenza these are
all potential causes and I think just
for the time I'm going to skip this part
and let's end up with a good example
okay and all of you have passed through
this and you may pass through this again
in in the future but we are leaving the
pandemic but I think it's good to
reflect for you about why science is so
important and what has done for us in
the last three years
so this is uh we really don't know
exactly
how the virus spread from animals to
humans okay there's still quite a bit of
debate but we know that that first
initial outbreak happened in China
caused a large outbreak and what's
implicated were these markets where many
times you will put one animal with one
species on top of another and then
they're all breathing or urinating on
defecating on top of each other and
they're spreading uh spreading spreading
viruses
so that's where the out that initial
event happened
but going back to kind of those drivers
and why we really worry about pandemics
is this is this situation these are all
the airplane flights
between all the cities in the world
so you could take that map of airplane
flights and just put that on top of what
we found we saw
this is based on using molecular biology
or genomics what we saw about the spread
of the of the SARS cov2 virus or the
covid virus in the first three or four
months of the of the pandemic right
it's interesting that one of the only
non-stop flights from Wuhan which
started went exactly to Milan because of
the fashion industry you know Wuhan
produces a lot of the clothes that
Italian fashion makers use and there's a
direct flight in Italy was one of the
first a hardest first and hardest hit
countries that were that was affected by
uh by the covert pandemic so this is a
good example of how the world is moving
and how we're at increased risk for once
a virus happens that it spreads quickly
and these are some of the challenges
that we faced during the um the the
pandemic well first that this was a new
virus that was never experienced by any
of us not only in this room but in the
world you know um prior to the pandemic
and that virus because we never
experienced it none of us had immunity
we were all susceptible to that to that
virus
the second is is that this was a virus
because new we had we didn't understand
its biology this is the importance of
science without understanding its
biology we can't we can't make
diagnostic tests we can't make therapies
or treatments to treat people who got
sick we can't prevent it by making with
making vaccines
and so forth
so so that was a key challenge the next
was that this was a highly transmissible
virus
because many of you I probably more than
50 percent of you have gotten covid uh
in this room whether you knew it or not
but this is a virus that could be
transmitted before you got sick
which is important because if I'm sick
I'll stay in my room but if I don't know
if I can transmit it before I get sick
maybe I don't know and I'm going to to
classes and meeting people and the other
was what we call Super spreading where
that you know where that one one PR uh
one person may spread it more to more
people than another person which makes
it very difficult to identify who is the
person who's actually
causing Transmission in the in the
community
the other problem as we you know sorely
learned in the beginning of the pandemic
is that this was a a leaf of our more
virulent virus more virulent than
influenza okay with the people and then
the further challenges as we progress
through the pandemic one was mutations
okay does everybody have you heard about
mutations
right good good so this virus like all
of us we have mutations that are
happening in our bodies but this virus
had mutations
whose strains were selected for
which created more transmissible even
more highly transmissible variants
innovated the immune response some of
you may have heard of the Omicron
variant that's a good a good example so
this pandemic the pandemic we started
with is not the pandemic that we ended
with
and then I think the last one which was
really important is is that we did a lot
of good science we did a lot of catch-up
especially our biologists and
immunologists you know the chemists yep
Kobe can spread to animals so this is a
good example but that's a very good
question you guys are thinking about
contagion a lot
um so so we can we can get infections
from animals
but we can also pass those infections
back to animals
so a lot of good examples of dogs
getting covered cats getting covered
tigers in zoos getting covered giraffes
getting covered and dying of covid that
they didn't get from another animal they
got it from a The Zookeeper or they get
they got it from the pet owner I got
covet and that makes it very difficult
to control right if it's only humans
well there are things we can do with
humans like vaccinate but if it's
animals that are infected as well it's
going to be those type of diseases are
very difficult to to control you know
certainly eliminate or eradicate but
also to control in in the short term
so the other problem is is that we did a
lot of good science in biology
and in the chemistry and in the
um in the Immunology of the disease in
the genetics of the disease but we
didn't really do a lot of good
scientists and we didn't have a lot of
trained scientists working on those type
of Behavioral introduction uh
interventions those things that we can
do to make people get vaccinated more or
make people wear face masks or or ha or
promote what we
um social distancing there so that was
we need more scientists specifically in
this area that could give a good advice
to leaders and have the leaders make the
right right decisions
and this is just the aftermath right
we're kind of in the aftermath of the
pandemic we've had just the United
States alone over 1.1 million people who
died during this epidemic so large
devastating costs happened over waves
many of our population have gotten
infected many of our population have
also gotten vaccinated
and they're a really good
scientific achievements and this is
really how science can make for a better
Society in a healthier Society we had
molecular tests and Rapid tests we were
able to test the sewage water
to get to understand how much
transmission comes in the community
we learned early on that social
distancing and wearing face masks those
kind of barrier types of interventions
were effective uh we do in within the
six first six months of the pandemic we
learned that certain drugs like steroids
Then followed by monoclonal antibiotics
and antiviral agents were effective and
then I think probably the most important
one was safe and effective
vaccines such as maybe the vaccines that
many of you in this room have taken
these MRI are mRNA vaccines so those
were really great breakthroughs that
kept you know what could have been even
more devastating uh pandemic let um less
so and just to tell you that you know
there are a lot of people who worked on
this at Yale really heroic efforts this
is one group this is had the privilege
to lead it was called the Yale impact
team you know which mounted response
first week this is this is March 2nd of
2020 even before we had the first case
and doing things like using saliva
you're spit to detect whether you're
infected or not okay that the other was
that Wastewater surveillance setting up
in New Haven understanding whether we
had transmission or Not by testing the
sewage water
and one of the things that we had to do
was protect like in Brazil those photos
the people who are most vulnerable
in our population and who were they they
were first of all the people living in
the cities Hartford Waterbury New Haven
Bridgeport Stanford those cities which
were also the most vulnerable had the
highest what we call social
vulnerability index
this is where the cities that got hit
hardest in our communities during that
terrible first wave the other population
was their nursing homes
11 of all people of all our nursing home
residents
uh you know died during that first one
month of that of that of that pandemic
and that's when
you know this is I think the other part
which is that there's one thing that we
do day to day whether it's in the
laboratory or in the field in the
community to to get to do science and to
get evidence but the other key part is
to work with the leaders
in making Translating that evidence and
that science and putting it into action
and you know I had the privilege of
being called on as as Kurt said by
Governor Lamont to co-chair with
indranui who is a former CEO of PepsiCo
so somebody who wasn't a scientist but
it was important to get
a balance so that we could really uh we
could think of how we could first
protect this state and then how we could
reopen it because many of the people had
lost their employment people they needed
who were working the restaurants who
were working in taxi drivers and so
forth lost their jobs during that that
period so how could we safely reopen the
state and I think the major guiding
principle and this is I think really is
hopefully you know why science you know
as a as a justification why science is
important is is that you need science in
order to do everything else to reopen
the economy to keep people hospitals
safe to keep People Protected to
minimize harm that may occur if we were
too rigorous
in in keeping everybody at home you know
safe at home
people would be losing their jobs people
would be losing their their uh their
income they wouldn't have money to to
feed their children
so one of the two things just wanted to
highlight of that plan was we were
called in on April 13th which was the
peak of the pandemic first wave in
Connecticut as I mentioned 11 by then of
our nursing home residents had died and
one of the most important things is that
we didn't have enough tests we were
testing doing 200 tests
per week we were having all of our
Laboratories in this state Jackson Labs
Yale Harvard Healthcare all of them were
developing new tests but we had to get
them to the people
because the hospitals wouldn't allow
anybody to come in unless you were
diagnosed with with covid so we went
within two months from about 200 kids
per day to about 20 000 kids kids today
by using all the Laboratories all the
scientists just calling them all up it
was sort of like World War II you know
calling everybody up who could do a test
and getting them them on board
the second thing that we did was to
vaccinate people once the vaccines were
approved on December 22nd 2020 rolled
them out many of you may have seen
remembered we had these large testing
centers as well as large vaccination
centers you'd go in your car roll up
your sleeve close the wind open the
window and get vaccinated so all of that
was driven by science driven by Best
Practices that we had at that time and
that you could see that horrible first
epidemic and then how that that
decreased you know through time pretty
much because of vaccination and access
to health care and that that ends um
Kurt I'm going over a little bit is that
okay just a two more tour minutes so
yeah so so I think um that I think the
most important thing is that who you are
and this goes back to the foundational
principles of epidemiology our goal is
to control D Z's and protect the popular
and the populations that suffered most
during that initial phase of the
epidemic were the nursing home
population
but also our African-American and Latino
populations
African-Americans and Latinos died five
times more
than our white population in our state
during that first first wave
and the only answer to that was science
okay getting testing and vaccination to
those populations you can see by the End
by our third wave third pandemic wave we
had no difference between mortality
between our African-American population
and white population and another still
an elevated population uh increased risk
of dying among our Latino populations so
more work needs to be needs to be done
but large drops in mortality that
occurred because of the public health
action driven by science
so let me end up with just two slides
and and I think many of you and again
thank you Kurt it's really an honor to a
privilege to be talking especially this
is the first talk after the pandemic uh
but let me go back a little bit and just
think about what helped me when I was in
your position
um I I had really great mentor my high
school chemistry teacher was the one who
really my mother in my high school
chemistry teacher were probably the two
most important people in my lives in in
teaching me about science in in
motivating me and enjoying science right
and enjoying to talk about science
um I think the other people in my lives
were kind of the people during my
college
you know uh professors in in in medical
school where they said why don't you do
this you know pick an important question
okay and then go for it and for all of
you in this room
particularly the Young Generation these
are the important questions right how do
we reduce inequalities how do we reduce
poverty poverty how do we do we mitigate
hunger how do we address climate change
how do we do affordable and clean energy
those are the key issues this is not
just for public health but this is for
involves physics astronomy it involves
um you know sociology anthropology all
of the different different Sciences
the second is is that learn constantly
and put in practice the new things you
learn I'm still learning today and
importantly I'm learning from people
much younger than me I'm learning for I
was just in Brazil a month ago I'm
learning from the 14 and 15 year olds
they're telling me new things about
something I thought I knew something
about
um every time I meet them I think the
other thing that we don't really
emphasize as much but is to talk about
science
okay it's fun to talk about science but
also to be an advocate for science you
are the Future Leaders and we will need
more and more
scientists like you uh to to advise
leaders such as the governor or the
president and so forth about what's the
best way to move forward okay so your
role in in society is enormous
so with that let me end uh apologies
Kurt for going over but just say thank
you to everyone
[Applause]
[Music]